[Musique]
voilà et c'est antoine feu d'eau qui
aideront qu à mes côtés pour info ou
intox direction le créneau où les
tensions à la frontière russe alimente
la machine à fausse information
absolument en rafale avec une vidéo en
particulier impressionnante il faut bien
dire diffusée sur les réseaux sociaux
vous l'apercevez ici je vais tenter de
l'agrandir un petit peu pour vous elle a
été partagée notamment parce qu'on le 20
janvier dernier vu depuis trente cinq
mille fois on y voit ces images de
drones donc d'un déploiement de ce qui
ressemble à des militaires d'infanterie
en ondes de nombreux blindés exactement
aussi avec ce titre que je vous résume
vidéo d'une brigade mécanisée se
préparant pour le front le commentaire
n'est pas explicite en revanche il l'est
beaucoup plus sur un autre compte qui a
également partagé cette vidéo on la
retrouve là encore beaucoup de vue plus
de 130000 vous l'apercevez sur le tout
petit compteur en bas avec un titre pru
plus précis une brigade mécanisée
ukrainienne se prépare à prendre ces
positions de combat près de kharkiv
l'armée ukrainienne est bien différente
de celle qui a abandonné la crimi son
combat poursuit cet internaute avec ce
hashtag d'ukraine kreis 6 laissant
entendre que la vidéo fait référence
donc à la crise actuelle problème de ces
images antoine elles sont fausses alors
oui et non raphaël si la vidéo est
authentique cessa décontextualisation
qui la rend fausse % en contre il suffit
d'utiliser un outil qu'on utilise
régulièrement ici info ou intox de
recherche d'image inversée vous en avez
l'habitude et on retrouve l'origine de
la vidéo originale donc sa première mise
en ligne cette vidéo la voix si vous
l'apercevez ici est là elle est là
étaient eux le plot des sur youtube en
mars 2020 le 5 très exactement par ce
conte défense express
la légende de la vidéo en ukrainien
précis je voulais traduit que défense
express a pu filmer un exercice d'une
brigade mécanisée de l'armée ukrainienne
dans un champ de tir alors défense
express est une entreprise ukrainienne
de conseil et d'information dans le
domaine militaire est aussi partenaire
de l'industrie de défense ukrainienne
des informations un très facilement
accessibles sur le site même de
l'entreprise est en lien donc avec cette
même vidéo marc fin mot de l'histoire à
exercice ou bien préparatifs à la guerre
alors la vidéo montre bien des troupes
ukrainienne donc lors d'un exercice une
brigade d'infanterie mécanisée très
précisément des articles d'ailleurs de
la presse ukrainienne que nous avons pu
retrouver datant de mars 2020 le précise
dans leurs colonnes en revanche
impossible de savoir à travers ses
articles de quand précisément et où ces
exercices ont eu lieu vous le voyez donc
on retrouve là encore des mécanismes
classiques de l'ain fox une vidéo
authentique des tournées ici elle a été
reprise par des comptes nationalistes
ukrainiens sur les réseaux sociaux donc
on reste dans le contexte de la crise du
crédit n'avaient qu'une autre intox
homophobe c'est toi oui avec le
détournement d'une autre vidéo vous
allez tout comprendre c'est cette vidéo
ici que je vais tenter de lire pour vous
voilà donc cette vidéo qui est partagé
par ce conte géorgien ses utilisateurs
facebook de géorgie il partage qui
ressemble à un clip promotionnel des
images sont bien léché et on y voit un
soldat homosexuel rentrer chez lui et
embrasser son compagnon saison à la fin
de la vidéo mais je vous la résume
rapidement vous remarquerez également en
bas à gauche de la vidéo je ne sais pas
si on peut le voir vous apercevez ici ce
petit logo ce logo il c'est celui des
forces armées ukrainiennes censées
authentifié donc sa provenance et leur a
été diffusé donc par l'armée ukrainienne
pour recruter le commentaire au dessus
de la vidéo et lui ouvertement homophobe
je vous en livre une traduction vont-ils
vraiment faire la guerre une telle
nation ne mérite pas d'exister problème
est bien au delà du commentaire c'est
que cette vidéo est fausse et largement
déformé le site de fact checking
géorgien miss détecteur à décortiquer
l'info qu'il s'agit en réalité d'une
vidéo datant de 2012 elle a été tournée
au royaume uni par la coalition pour le
mariage de même sexe là où ça devient
intéressant raphaël c'est l'origine de
la fausse vidéo avec le logo en lui même
mis detector a remonté sa trace
numérique elle provient de plusieurs
comptes en géorgie d'abord elle a été
publiée le 27 janvier par un mouvement
autoproclamé mouvement conservateur
ouvertement islamophobe
plus intéressant encore la vidéo est
homophobe homophobes par donc
suffisamment hausse est bien de me
corriger à la vidéo a donc également été
publié en 2001 cette fois par
représentant de la république
autoproclamée de lougansk elle a par la
suite été reprises en ils 21 cette fois
par plusieurs utilisateurs russes pour
affirmer que l'otan créée soit disant
des bataillons lgbt dont vous le voyez
la crise ukrainienne est aussi un
vecteur puissant de désinformation est
aussi l'affrontement de deux visions
d'une société merci antoine fenaux info
ou intox qui décortique pour nous
l'actualité et va à la chasse aux
fausses informations